the next round of
stimulus includes a provision for the
business liability protection and what
business liability protection is
is a rule that would broadly shield
businesses from liability
should somebody file a claim saying that
they contracted covet 19
while on the premises or engaged in
business
with that particular establishment so
that way a business can
hire employees back without being afraid
that they're going to be subject to a
lawsuit
advocates of the liability protection
say that if you're a small business
and somebody accuses you of maintaining
an environment where catching
coronavirus is likely
that the amount of time energy and money
it takes to fight off this kind of
lawsuit
even if you win is enough to bankrupt
already struggling businesses
businesses have found that they can ask
for waivers
but in many of the states waivers are
considered
unenforceable there's also a concern
from an interstate commerce perspective
that
by having various standards it creates
confusion
for businesses and thereby increases
their cost and therefore
a desire to have a uniform
standard generally speaking
this proposal is tantamount
to providing absolute immunity for
businesses
detractors of liability legislation say
that the widespread immunity from
lawsuits would unfairly place the burden
of proof on an employee or customer
to show that they contracted the virus
at a particular business or workplace
that's kind of a difficult task to do
it's very hard to prove where you
actually came down with coronavirus or
even the common cold
the standards in the proposal in
particular
if someone were to bring a claim someone
will have to enumerate
when they believe they may have gotten
covid19
and do a form of contact tracing before
they can even bring a claim
the bill changes the standard
from a preponderance of the evidence
to clear and convincing evidence
that significantly raises the bar
in a negligence claim
it notes that a lawyer
can be held legally responsible as well
as their law firm
for writing a demand letter
that is later determined or
characterized
as frivolous because it did not meet
these
recent and higher standards established
in this bill this bill is about
reopening yes but reducing
costs of operations for businesses
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
and senator john cornyn have proposed
these rules to broadly shield businesses
who make what they call a good
faith effort to protect their employees
from contracting the virus
as written the proposed standard would
extend all the way through 2024
and it would also apply retroactively to
when the coronavirus first began to
circulate in december of 2019.
employees may not have
as much flexibility to not return to the
workforce
or their jobs and those employers
may not be as conscientious
if you will because the liability rules
give them almost absolute immunity
liability protection is a red line in
particular for senator mcconnell
he is up for re-election in november and
he's repeatedly stated
that the issue of liability protection
is paramount to legislation moving
forward